[Music]
what you doing
there
yeah you're such a happy baby shya my
hasus been wanted to go to uh cake place
for weeks cuz the cakes are amazing are
they mhm you'll see them very soon it's
nice we're in like a central part but
it's very quiet
here maybe do a back flip or
[Music]
something it was uh full so we got take
out instead look at this
packaging the finest tiny
Mountain oh it smells so good so it's a
replica of a real mountain but I don't
know which one it is M oh my God I love
it it's raspberry chocolate I love that
I China I
[Music]
think frogo is back it's been so
long
he he's probably hunting so
I'm just going to leave him and not try
and move him but I am going to print him
something I just haven't had
time frogo is
back there's nothing in
it where's
oh M it got better the more flavors I
got oh we got different
layers stand
still every everyone wants to see more
merch in the Vlogs there you
[Music]
[Applause]
go oh
banana today's beautiful day maybe we'll
see some fall leaves we're also going to
head to OT Sando now to check out CeX
they invited us they have baby product
for be that they offered so we're going
to pimp you out
[Music]
be
look at you with your Swedish backpack
today we're going on a hike I'm really
excited de loves to be outside so why
not we're going to go up a mountain
Mount cow Mar has already done it that's
why she comes prepared but I never so
and I think it will be really nice and
fallik
so such a pretty day for a mountain
climb we're going to look for some food
before we go up oh I don't know if you
can see it but all the leaves are
[Music]
falling we haven't even started but it's
so
[Music]
pretty
she caught
[Music]
one what a
PR little Mario pap
birthday
[Music]
cute giant
stairs or the
slope you want to do it
no okay so we're like halfway got a
backpack and a baby I do have the stick
so it's
okay they're getting cooked
here
[Music]
so many pretty
Tempo such a pretty
area we're not at the summer yet I don't
know where it
[Music]
is me where I am
me almost
there oh
boy I'm getting a soft ice
cream first thing we we get
now look at these
mountains what a mountain ring
we made
it oh my God I'm under attack by
[Music]
leaves I think it took us like an hour
longer than it should have but it was so
great
the walk down is so much nicer cuz
there's way less people what a day B
loves it he's just been sucking on his
fingers the past hour not bad with such
a view either
wow
[Music]
damn
all right that concludes our little
Ascent I was saying to my say I think
this is my favorite fall day I've ever
had I waited all day for
this it's really good I just breathe in
the
matcha
the dog's
[Music]
funny damn we're in he Park we're going
to check out the Christmas
lights wherever they are
this is so
unreal what a magnificent
Garden turns out they moved the market
that we were going to to another Park 50
minutes away so we're doing a quick
little stroll and I never actually been
to be Park it's really really really
[Music]
pretty oh
sorry
damn right the are so cool what so are
these called goo trees yeah it means
gold in Japanese fun fact about the
trees they're beautiful but if you step
on the fruit it smells just like dog
poop and I don't see any fruit look at
this one it's got like
droopy I don't know how that's even
[Music]
possible we made it to the other Park
there's gigle everywhere here I've never
seen so
many everyone's going out on the streets
to take photos cuz it's so
pretty Ken said that be has a really
round
[Laughter]
face yes you
do
[Music]
wow
wow your hands are
[Music]
free oh sor stop burn it in the
fire I kill it I hate it I hate it he's
biting it he's biting it hey
[Music]
you look at those that looks so
good
oh he did
yay interrupting today's sponsor nordvpn
more VPN best VPN the most VPN of vpns
as you guys know nordvpn doesn't just
let you quickly connect to anywhere
across the globe look at this I'm in
Japan boom I'm in Bosnia and her heroina
jum I'm in Ireland top of the morning to
your I'm in Australia right next to the
kangaroos how MO mean that's how you
sound like Australian and you know
sometimes when you buy stuff online
prices are cheaper in different
countries same product same thing just
cheaper Try It Out n VPN also keep you
safe with amazing features like threat
protections nowadays antivirus software
seems like they are the virus software
we all just pop at oh
BL I don't want to hear it nordvpn just
runs smoothly in the background keeping
you safe you don't even have to think
about it with features like threat
protection protecting your downloads
trackers malicious ads and protecting
you from Bad websites you're not going
to bad websites are you okay as long as
you have no VPN there okay okay picture
this you're at PewDiePie headquarters
this is a real scenario and you're about
to meet the big man himself but the
secretary Edgar tells you you have to
wait 5 minutes so you think okay I'll
whip by my phone I'll just connect to
the public Wi-Fi what is this proo WiFi
no password okay I'll connect to that
and boom I knock at the door I jump out
and go ha I got everything oh all your
data all your stuff you fool and I slap
you across the face and I go you should
have used nordvpn you failed the test
and then I take your face and I just get
up anyway you should always use n VPN
when you connect to a public Wi-Fi to
protect so right before I go I'll I'll
say Hey you get one more chance go to
nordvpn.com PewDiePie use the link and
get a huge discount and four additional
months for free you're welcome
anyway thanks for Norv for sponsoring
this
[Music]
video
wow wo
[Music]
wo we're at yomi Ur Lando they have
Christmas illumination so we thought
we'd check it out it's about 3: 3:00
p.m. now there's so many amusement park
I have never heard of in Japan so we
just saw this one and we thought we'
check it
[Music]
out I feel like when you go to Disney
land you more or less know what to
expect right but you go to a place like
this it's like I have no
idea
[Music]
going that was so fun you can see all
the Tokyo at the top I really like that
one
[Music]
so I I was like oh moment is so
cuddling there's ice cream right there
[Music]
yes done that's all
black
we're both enjoying a
snake we're in ki Joie I never been here
before we're going to check out a
market a friend has like a s saw I am
extremely tired but I got chocolate that
I should do
[Music]
it I forgot to say it's like
21° and it's middle of December I'm
loving
[Music]
it
B
don't steal my
glasses there you
go hello Jen we're going to Museum oh my
God oh my
God be is teething and it's been a
really fun time right be but going out
and doing stuff kind of
helps
whenever I see giant Gardens like this I
can't help think how much the the line
would be quite cool to find these
Gardens in the middle of Tokyo so
[Music]
Central you got your little bunny
bearing yay cuz you're the year of the
bunny you could have been the year of
the dragon that would have been
[Music]
cooler is it time for a baby review B is
almost 6 months now one or two more
weeks we just came out of like the worst
two weeks ever with be I was telling
Maria how well he was sleeping and I
don't really get why people complain you
sleep through the night almost and then
all of a sudden as if he heard me sleep
regression just hit and he wouldn't
sleep at all so that was really
tough but you sleep so well now you're
back on track we've been feeling it for
a while but you really start feeling
that sort of parent love for your child
like there's no feeling like
it because you are the cutest baby in
the world be did you know that actually
all babies are the cutest in the world
but you are the cutest in the world and
we love you very much we built this
chair it must have been over a year ago
and now you can finally sit in it
yay what are you doing with the tongue I
want to eat a little Japanese
man
how's it going look at you
guys
yay so cute the Shel
Berg's first
[Music]
Christmas holy moly that
same have a Hol Christmas
[Music]
y hey we got a l cion aome cute super
good go
here go here y
yeah we got the ulas for breakfast oh
that's
forbidden will I get the
Almond you got last year mhm it's great
that's right I got the Almond I get to
open my
gift thank
you
he scalp there
room I need it we got a dry scalp so
thank you this is for you
[Music]
be the biggest package of all Santa came
and
delivered stop making that
face the pilot getting strapped
in he's ready to runch
[Music]
wow
W he's supposed to be on his teles it's
not supposed to be okay so check this
out be you can actually spin on this
thing it's like your little Command
Center here's your assistant
Mr Mr
blowy
damn
[Music]
next the
now back to
now
yay
[Music]
me
he's
hiding there he
is hey
[Music]
where's big day for be today he's about
to have
his very excited be's about to have your
first meal ever mommy has prepared a
potato cuz Mommy loves potatoes are you
going to love
potatoes that looks good be this
oh so
exciting what a big moment for you
be
M interesting flavor you got some in
your map
there oh well done
J
yay well
done
you did
[Music]
it